ah si on peut prier mais ça donne rien
Dieu à qui nous devons de naître nous
dépendons de toi en toute chose
accorde-nous les pluies dont nous avons
besoin
afin qu'ils ont rassuré pour les fruits
de la terre nous puissions mieux
rechercher les biens d'éternité par
Jésus-Christ ton Fils notre Seigneur
AMEN
monsieur le curé avez-vous déjà eu
l'occasion de prononcer de telles
prières dans votre vie d'ecclésiastique
et bien les certains que pour connaître
une sécheresse comme ça je me souviens
absolument pas à avoir
béni la terre ni les champs il est vrai
que mon ministère jusque-là était
totalement en ville alors évidemment
toutes ces questions rurales sont assez
loines étaient assez loin de mes
préoccupations
et s'il ne pleut pas et s'il ne pleut
pas bien vous savez que de tout temps
dans l'église il y a eu des prières pour
les besoins de la terre jadis même à
travers tous ces champs il y avait des
processions c'était l'érrogation et bien
je suis sûr que ces prières adressaient
à Dieu ne seront pas sans réponse et que
ce problème de la sécheresse a peut-être
un peu s'arranger si on peut prier mais
ça donne à rien et là j'ai des
betteraves de fête
[Applaudissements]
oui même si on dit pas de panique un
rien d'angoisse saisit les gens dans
l'attente de la pluie qui ne vient pas
ou qui vient au dépit du bon sens ainsi
les autorités religieuses catholiques et
musulmanes ont demandé aux fidèles de
prier pour la pluie comme d'autres avant
lui l'évêque de Strasbourg Monseigneur
et le changer a ordonné des prières dans
toutes les églises de son diocèse
l'Alsace est une des régions les plus
touchées par la sécheresse Bernard
Chevalier a rencontré en compagnie de
l'évêque de Strasbourg un agriculteur
dans son champ obligé de couper du
fourrage pour nourrir les bêtes l'évêque
explique pourquoi les chrétiens prient
pour la pluie
est-ce que vous souffrez déjà de la
sécheresse ici Monsieur
Madame
ça commence et qu'est-ce que vous faites
pour ça quels sont les moyens que vous
avez pour essayer ils vont commencer à
forcer les céréales ça va pas autant
qu'est-ce que vous avez prié pour
demander la pluie
pour le moment on est vous attendez
toujours
quand même vous voyez dans toute la
France on souffle la sécheresse et vous
l'église vous ordonnez des prières pour
la pluie pourquoi vous le faites tout
d'un coup alors que depuis des années on
le faisait plus
je ne sais pas si on le faisait plus
mais pour nous qui avons la foi Dieu
nous considère comme ces collaborateurs
pas comme des esclaves qui exécutent des
collaborateurs or quelqu'un qui a des
collaborateurs il est consulte la prière
pour nous c'est une manière d'être
consulté par Dieu c'est une manière de
le consulter alors c'est pas pour
demander des miracles ça rentre dans le
jeu de Dieu qui est pour les croyants le
maître et du soleil et de la pluie moi
j'estime que les gens qui ont la foi ils
doivent continuer comme autrefois à
confier au Seigneur leur souci et
actuellement cette sécheresse qui peut
devenir une catastrophe nationale
[Musique]